in this table we have the price range in
one row and the frequency in another
15 pens that cost between 10 and 20
rupees were sold
20 pens that cost between 20 and 30
rupees were sold and so on
frequency is simply the number of times
something has occurred or you can say
how frequently something has occurred
and these intervals as we can see are
continuous
the upper limit of 1 is the same as the
lower limit of its next interval
we saw how we can draw a histogram for
continuous class intervals
we have the x and the y-axis
we have the class intervals on the
x-axis
and the frequency on the y-axis
for the interval 10 to 20 we draw a bar
to represent 15 pens
for 20 to 30 we draw a bar to represent
20 pens
observe that here there are no gaps
between the bars like we had in the bar
graph
in the same way we draw bars for the
remaining three intervals
we use histograms to represent class
intervals
while drawing a histogram we have the
class intervals on the x-axis
while for a bar graph we have categories
but here's something really interesting
sometimes we may not need to draw the
entire histogram
instead of drawing bars for the
histogram we draw something like this
let's remove the bars and see how it
looks
this just about tells you what the
frequency is for a particular class
interval
this is called the frequency polygon
frequency as it represents the frequency
of each class interval
and polygon as it has many sides
there are two ways to draw this and we
have made two separate videos for each
make sure you watch them
you